-Please, please.
-[ British accent ] Please sit.
-Please. I know, please.
-Sit, please.
-No, you sit. You sit, as well.
-Sit.
You have to sit first.
-Yeah, I know.
-It's -- It's polite.
-I love your accent.
-Oh, thank you.
I love yours.
-Oh, really? Well...
-Yeah.
-[ British accent ] It's
just that -- I just grew up in,
um...
-Yeah.
-What -- What part of London
is this voice?
-[ South London accent ]
It's probably like South London.
-Oh, wow!
You can do South London?
-South London.
-But how do you make it
sound cute, even...
-[ Normal voice ]
I don't think I do.
-Yeah, you do. You sound cute.
What a year you're having, pal.
I want to talk about --
dude, you have the --
you're on the biggest show
in the world, "Game of Thrones."
You're -- You're about to be...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
...in the biggest movie,
"Dark Phoenix."
And on top of it all, the best
news -- you just got married.
-I did.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, yes!
-Yes!
-You did it!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-I did it!
-You did it!
You showed 2019 what's up!
-I did.
-You're like,
"2018, hold my beer."
You know what I'm saying?
-"Hold my beer."
[ Laughter ]
-You married Joe Jonas,
who we love, and...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this guy. Oh, my God.
That's what I'm talking about.
Look at this couple.
-Ooh-whee!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fashion plates right there.
I saw you at the Met Gala.
-Yes, recently.
-I -- Yeah, it was really fun,
though.
It was like --
The theme was camp.
-The theme was camp.
-Yes.
And so --
-So...
- Everyone's very campy.
-Everyone was very camp.
-Yes.
[ Light laughter ]
And did you have fun?
-I had a great time.
I didn't quite know
what camp meant.
But I figured sequins
and colors would do.
-Sure.
-Sure. Why not?
And matching --
isn't that quite camp?
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It totally is camp, yeah.
-I had glitter in my hair
that I found --
I keep finding
in my belly button.
[ Laughter ]
-That -- See, that's --
That's when you know
you had a fun night...
-Yeah.
-When you find glitter
in your belly button.
-I had a really good night.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The best part is, it's
a cardboard cutout of Joe Jonas.
You didn't even come with him.
You just --
-No, I didn't.
-You just --
You're just -- You're holding...
-I'm not actually married to
him.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not even really married.
Sure, it's perfect.
-No, I just took
his cardboard cutout
to the little white chapel
and married him.
-I have actually someone that --
a fan of yours send
in a video question.
-Oh, you did?
-I did.
Would you like to take one?
-I would love to.
-This is a question from a fan.
I think his name is Joe.
Joe, what's your question?
-Oh.
-Oh, my God.
Hi, Sophie Turner.
I'm Joe Jonas.
I'm a huge fan.
I --
I honestly have a crush on you.
But I have got a big question
for you.
Um, I-I watch a lot
of "Game of Thrones."
And I was wondering --
you're definitely responsible
for that coffee cup, right?
[ Audience ohs ]
-Yes!
It was you!
-It's w-- Okay.
-Lookit. Here's the scene.
-Let's clear this up.
[ Laughter ]
-Look, here's the scene.
Here's the scene right here.
Look at that.
And this is the scene.
And what is that right there?
[ Laughter ]
That is a Starbucks coffee cup.
And you know what's funny
is that I saw a picture of
you...
-Mnh. Mnh.
-...holding a coffee cup!
-No!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Low notes play ]
-'Twas you!
-All right, Detective Pikachu.
[ Laughter ]
This -- Okay, let me --
for all of you guys that watch
"Game of Thrones"...
-Yeah.
-And this is a spoiler
for a couple of episodes ago.
This girl dies --
[ Laughter ]
In an episode --
one of the episodes.
And this is the scene
from the episode after she dies.
So, why am I holding this
coffee cup?
[ Audience ohhs ]
That's in a different scene.
And, also...
we all have the same cups
for all of our water and tea
and everything.
So I'm gonna just go with --
I mean, look who it's placed
in front of.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa!
[ Audience ohs ]
Wow. Emilia --
-Emilia Clarke.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my. Really?
-She's the culprit.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
Did --
-You're a terrible detective.
-Well, I got that out of you,
didn't I?
-Well, you did.
[ Chuckles ]
-Did you --
Did everyone text each other?
All the actors on
"Game of Thrones" be like,
"Dude,
did you guys see that cup?"
-[ Chuckles ] Well, yeah, no.
There was just, like, one text.
And it was from Nikolaj,
who plays...
-Yeah.
-...Jaime Lannister.
And he just wrote,
"Great episode.
Is that a coffee cup?"
[ Laughter ]
-I know we can't talk about
what -- what --
what's gonna happen.
There's only
a couple episodes left.
-No, we can.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, no, we -- No, we can't.
No, that wasn't -- nope.
-God, why do you guys --
you guys all come on the show.
And you're such good actors.
Like, did you see
what we did with Maisie...
- Maisie.
-...Maisie Williams?
-Her hands were shaking.
-Dude, she -- her --
-She had tears in her eyes.
-Her acting was so good.
I hated doing that bit.
-Yeah, you --
-I felt so bad.
I felt bad for her.
-Yeah, 'cause she looks like
a tiny little girl,
and you were just...
-And she was just, like,
crumbling.
She thought she did
a fake spoiler.
It was an April Fool's joke
that we did.
And I don't even like --
I don't even do those jokes.
I don't like getting tricked.
No one --
please don't trick me.
I don't like tricking people.
I don't like it.
But then you almost
did something.
But then you didn't do it.
But then,
can you tell us -- do you die?
[ Laughter ]
Come on. No, we don't know,
but, look -- here --
Look, on --
This is a pain scale.
[ Laughter ]
A pain measurement scale
from a doctor's office.
Now, from -- from zero to 10,
how much pain will we feel
at the end of "Game of Thrones"?
-Ohh.
-Not you personally.
-The audience?
-The audience, yeah.
-Okay, all right.
You're gonna...
-Hm.
I mean, it's probably gonna be
around...
-No pain?
-[ Gasps ] There!
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh!
You're --
-It will be.
-[ British accent ] There!
-There!
Did I sound very English there?
-[ Normal voice ]
No, it was great.
-There.
-There!
-There -- The thespians.
The English thespians.
-Why be here
when I can be there?
[ Laughter ]
Can we talk about
"Dark Phoenix" now?
-Oh, yeah, sure.
-This is a giant, giant movie.
I don't even know if people
understand how much work
goes into these superhero films.
-It's a lot of work.
-It is a lot of --
This costume is just one thing.
But, also, you're doing
a lot of flying.
-Yeah, a lot of flying.
-Which means --
and I'm saying --
spoiler alert --
she really can't fly
in real life.
Sorry, guys.
I know. Spoiler alert.
But there's trickery --
there's trickery involved.
-There is.
[ Both chuckle ]
-It's not really called that.
But you're on wires, right,
when you're levitating?
-Actually, originally,
I wasn't on wires.
I was on this thing that we call
the parallelogram.
And it was basically like
there were weights on one end,
and then this kind of bike seat
on the other.
And so I would have to kind of
prop myself up on the bike seat
like that and dangle my legs.
And then they would lift me up
into the air by my crotch,
which was just wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
But on top of that,
I was wearing -- I was --
So, for all
of the flying scenes,
I'm wearing, like,
this purple leather jacket
with this huge collar
that comes up like this.
-Yeah.
-And all the hair is CGI'd,
so I have to wear a bald cap.
[ Laughter ]
And so...
I look like Megamind...
[ Laughter ]
...with bad crotch pains.
-"Bad Crotch Pains" --
I'm happy they didn't go
with that title for the movie.
[ Laughter ]
-There I am.
-"Dark Phoenix" is much better.
That's you levitating?
-Don't I look so dangerous?
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show a clip.
Here is Sophie Turner
in "Dark Phoenix."
Hey, before we show this clip,
any spoilers?
-Um...
everyone -- everyone dies.
[ Light laughter ]
-Don't go there.
-Don't go there. Go over there.
-Yeah! Here, here.
-"Dark Phoenix," take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-Look, I know who you are.
I don't want to fight.
-No, you don't.
[ Whirring ]
-Stop that.
I said stop that right now.
-It's not me.
-It's me.
-Jean.
♪♪
Jean!
-Get down!
♪♪
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sophie Turner, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]